hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
on the podcast we've occasionally talked
about moral philosophy
right what is right what is wrong how do
we decide these things in fact
i'm kind of more interested and
knowledgeable about meta ethics
than i am about ethics so metaethics
being how do we decide
what is right and wrong versus ethics
which is what is right and what is wrong
but no matter what your choices are but
how decide what is right and what is
wrong
as a society there will be people who
don't
listen to you right who violate the
rules who break the laws who act in ways
that you've decided were wrong
what do you do about those people and
generally speaking whether it's a
dictatorship or a democracy or whatever
generally speaking the end result is we
throw them in jail
sometimes there's the death penalty or
financial things but
throwing people in either jail or prison
incarcerating them in other words
is the most common way to punish people
for serious crimes in the modern world
so that raises questions who should be
incarcerated
what should be the process by which we
decide who is incarcerated
and it's very interesting that here in
the united states where i live
we are completely an outlier worldwide
the united states has the largest prison
population in the world
and the highest per capita incarceration
rate
in some sense this is a recent
phenomenon we've we've increased the
number of people who are incarcerated by
four times uh since 1980. so something
has happened we're putting a lot more
people
in prison why is that and is it the
right thing to do so today i'm talking
to charis kubrin
who is a criminologist who studies this
whole phenomenon of incarceration both
who gets incarcerated
and should they get incarcerated one
specific thing we talk about not just
the general theory of incarceration
though there is that
but one of her expertises is let's put
it this way
would you be happy if you were on trial
and the prosecutor brought up your
youthful poetry as evidence that you
were in a bad state of mind
i mean maybe you had written some poetry
that was violent or misogynistic or
something like that
okay well how about if instead of poetry
it was rap lyrics turns out that if
you're a young person and you've written
violent rap lyrics
those lyrics that you wrote as a youth
are more likely to be held against you
in a criminal trial
than other things that maybe would be
more relevant
so charis has actually done a lot of
work both
academically and also in briefs before
appellate courts and so forth on why
that is not a good idea you should not
take people's rap lyrics
as confessions to crimes it's an art
form it's poetry
there could be people who are very
violent offenders and also rap artists
but that's not a necessary relationship
i don't know is this true is this a good
idea so that's what we're going to talk
about we're going to talk about this
whole set of ideas involving who should
be put into prison and jail
and how we actually do it and why the
united states is so different than
other places whether it even works right
is it true that throwing people in jail
or in prison
decreases crime it's not obvious but uh
social science very very complicated
wherever people are involved the
questions become much harder so
let's go
welcome to the mindscape podcast thank
you so you're dealing with one of these
topics i occasionally have on the
podcast
where many people who are listening
including well myself who i'm talking
uh will not be an expert in the area and
yet have strong opinions right when
we're talking about car incarceration
crime
race things like that so why don't we
just start with some background
knowledge because people do have these
opinions but your database do you
actually have the numbers and you can
help us
get straight i mean is the general
feeling that here in the united states
uh we have an international audience but
we here in the united states have a
feeling amongst ourselves that we
incarcerate a lot of people
how how accurate is that feeling yeah
it's it's accurate it was particularly
accurate in the early 2000s
up to about 2011 and this is when
our field of criminology saw the
introduction of new terms i mean this is
how you know something is a big deal
when new terms like mass incarceration
uh come onto the scene and so we've the
united states
um is definitely the place where we
incarcerate at the highest rate compared
to anywhere
students are still surprised to hear
that we got better around 2011 with
rates going down a little bit but we
still
far outstrip you know pretty much
anywhere else in the world in terms of
our incarceration rates unfortunately
so not only do we outstrip you know
france and canada and japan
but you know some of the biggest
repressive dictatorships in the world
we're much better putting people in jail
we don't typically compare ourselves to
yes
and again just to you know set the
landscape so we know what's going on is
that
mostly a federal issue is it a state
issue you know
why is it that we're so good at putting
people in prison
it's mostly a state issue so i mean we
still have it an issue at the federal
level but the bulk of
people incarcerated in the united states
are in state level institutions
um we it's uh i could give a whole
lecture on
the buildup of mass incarceration its
disproportionate effect on certain
populations
um i could go on and on but in in short
term we've just punished too many people
for far too long and so we've grown
pretty severe in what we choose to
punish in terms of casting the net out
quite widely
and then we've enacted policies like
mandatory sentencing
truth and sentencing that really punish
individuals for quite a long time
relative
to the crimes that they've committed
right so that makes
sense both of those factors make perfect
sense let me let me just dig in a little
bit more
to both of them um when you say that we
incarcerate a lot of people
is that the kinds of crimes or just even
very minor crimes we throw people in
prison for
yeah i think it's a little bit of both i
so i think we've identified
crimes for which in other places perhaps
the the result is not to incarcerate an
individual rehabilitation or other
form of supervision um i'll take
california my state for example
um we just started criminalizing very
low level drug offenses
in particular that helped build up the
population in our prisons
and in the last several years have had
to enact several reforms
which have moved many of these crimes to
lower offenses for which
prison was not now not the uh the
outcome if you will
and i guess you know one could still
make the argument maybe
people do that we're doing it right and
everyone else is doing it wrong is there
a is there a feeling out there in the
community about that
no yeah i mean i've been on
i've i've i've been on radio shows and
others where i've been
arguing opposite of someone else who
thinks the system is working great we're
doing a great job
um and i i guess i would say you know
it's good to be number one for
in a lot of things in the united states
but having the the most
individuals incarcerated per capita is
not something to be proud of it to me
it's a
it suggests a system that is over
incarcerating and i think there's
finally realization of that on both the
left and the right
and this is why we've had reforms all
over the united states
in particular california my state has
really done a lot to turn the ship
around um and that was prompted
in 2011 by the supreme court stepping in
and saying
this this is the conditions in
california state prisons are
so horrible the overcrowding is so
problematic
that you need to find a way to very
quickly reduce your prison
population and this is not a notoriously
left-leaning supreme court saying yes
exactly right i mean it's bad it's bad
to begin with it's really bad when
you know the supreme court steps in and
says let this has to be fixed and
california did
well you mentioned drug offenses in
particular and i think that's the thing
that you hear
more often than anywhere else the united
states is just
crazy about throwing people in jail or
in prison for drug offenses including
relatively minor ones is that
a big cause of our leading the world
that's part of it but there's there's so
many other i mean just low-level
kinds of crimes thefts and other things
um
numbers of priors being a major
determinant of incarcerating people for
long periods of time
excessive sentences once individuals are
convicted we have a problems with
basically probation and parole parole in
particular
when an individual is incarcerated and
then let out early on parole
and then does something that constitutes
a violation of that parole
they go right back to prison in
california at least they did
prior to these reforms and so we we kept
filling the prisons back up with people
that were violating parole
on their very first time for example so
not a lot of chances given
a lot you know harsh penalties for
relatively minor crimes
you know so this at the end of the day
creates the build-up
we just had as we're recording this
didn't we just have like a week or two
ago a supreme court decision saying it
was okay to throw
juvenile offenders in prison without
possibility of parole
forever um i'm not i've been
really slammed last week okay
uh yeah they're probably i'm i'm not i
haven't been keeping up with
with that so i'm not what happened yeah
there was i remember i mean um
uh sonia sotomayor i think wrote a
blistering descent as one does but there
was a 63
decision and i'm not going to get the
details right but basically yeah
it made it much easier to throw
juveniles in for life without any
possibility of parole
which a lot of people were saying like
how do you ever judge
especially when certain members of the
supreme court are known for their own
youthful indiscretions
well absolutely that's why we have an
entire juvenile justice system because
we recognize that youth are quite
different in their development
than adults and so they shouldn't be
held accountable in the same ways
as adults there should be more
rehabilitation and is there this is
probably going to take us a field we'll
we'll get back to focus a little bit but
i can see where is in the united states
if you're
a politician campaigning you want to get
elected then saying
let's let more people out of prison is
not the
winning campaign slogan but that sounds
very
simplistic and why is that not the case
in other countries what is it about
us that makes us so different ah
i mean there there's just so much our
history the the role of politics in our
criminal justice system
has become in my opinion out of control
you will you're absolutely right
to their the left and the right can
never say
um we need you know we need to rethink
um
our policies and practices it's always
about getting tough on crime
um i i you know why we're different
is a really difficult question that i'm
not quite sure i have
i have the answer to or i know enough
about what's happening in other
countries to make those
comparisons but um you know i i do think
at least for
40 50 60 decades crime and getting tough
on crime the politization of crime has
been
very salient in our in our country and i
mean i remember in 1994 when the crime
bill was passed i remember when bill
clinton
was running i mean it was like a race
between the left and the right
as to who was going to be tougher on
crime
and so um yeah you're not going to get
elected you don't get votes
that's pretty much the norm of from
local politics to
to all the way up to the president well
in another way that the united states
stands out of course is in its gun laws
and its gun ownership
uh patterns is that is that a close uh
tie into the sentencing and the criminal
population or is it just two things that
are going in parallel
yeah i think that helps explain the
united states
rates of violence relative to other
countries so yes
absolutely guns gun ownership is a huge
part of that story
in terms of in terms of the you know how
it played into the question that you
asked prior i'm not exactly sure but
certainly when
criminologists talk about why is why is
violence so high why are homicide rates
so high in the us
guns are a key part of that conversation
100 okay so i mean we have we have a lot
of violent crime here in the united
states but it's not nearly enough to
account for all the incarceration right
so
so much of it is non-violent crime so
we're just incarcerating people right
left we like people throwing people in
prison
yeah we we tend to assume that the link
between crime and incarceration is
perfect right that it's correlated
you know you know um and there is
obviously some correlation but it's not
nearly a perfect correlation as one
might think there's so many other
factors that go
into um the incarceration rates and
and some of that i talked about before
but crime is only one part of it and and
you know the other assumption that
happens is we assume that incarcerating
people at a high rate will reduce crime
on the other end sort of
reverse causality and that's also been
shown not to necessarily be the case to
the extent that we would think it would
be
there's some debate but economists say
maybe 20 percent of the crime decline
for example
we had so crime really rose in the 80s
uh leveled off in the in sort of the
early 90s and started going down and
this has been the great american crime
decline
the crime drop um till about the mid
2000s
and criminologists have rushed to figure
out what it is that caused crime to go
down
and you know those that support this
harsh punishment will argue well we've
just incarcerated more people and that's
brought the crime down but
uh only about 20 percent of that decline
has been attributed to um
to punishment basically yeah i mean
there's certainly a lot to talk about in
terms of uh
why people are committing crimes how
much they're committing the last
question i have on sort of the
background
incarceration question is what about the
role of private prisons
versus state-run ones like this is
something i know nothing about but it's
definitely one of the phrases i hear
being bandied about this is the most
under
discussed topic that is on the horizon
that is a huge obstacle for this country
when obama was president he was
beginning to phase out private
private prisons in fact at the federal
level he was
closing them all down trump came in
and i don't know if you noticed but when
trump was elected president
stocks in private prisons skyrocketed
and did not notice
and what's interesting is there's no
appetite for private prisons with
respect to our general prison population
because of interest to minimize mass
incarceration so it's shifting
and it's shifting to immigrant
populations okay so for example what
we're seeing with
um trump's immigration policies was a
buildup of
privatization around immigrant detention
and right if you're going to identify
round up and
deport large swaths of people as
president trump wanted to do
you need places to hold individuals
right these sorts of things
so a lot of immigration um detention is
privatized
so that's been resurrected unfortunately
i have huge
i mean that you would it'd be rare to
find a criminologist that thinks this is
a good move
and i could spend days talking about the
problems associated with private prisons
you know i mean at its fundamental core
having institutions profit off of
having you know it's a business and and
that's a fundamental
concern among many critics of private
prisons
well it's it's very analogous i guess to
the health care situation right where
having
lots of money you can make by not giving
people health care
is uh is a problematic incentive
structure even if you believe in
capitalism
exactly exactly so yeah this is this is
growing i
in all my courses i have a segment on
private prisons and when i show the
growth of private prisons
and the number of companies involved and
employees i mean it's a
whole it's a whole beast
some exciting news for fans of our
sponsors here on mindscape
the great courses plus is now wondriam
onerium is everything we know and love
about the great courses plus and much
more
one dream provides fantastic video and
audio
learning experiences tons of great
content to enrich our lives with
mind-blowing moments
you can still stream all of your
favorites from the great courses
including videos created in partnership
with national geographic smithsonian
history
the culinary institute of america and
more my favorite part of working with
the great courses
was that when i worked with them they
clearly cared about getting the content
right which means that if you're
watching something on one dream whether
it's
about the history of ancient egypt or
how to cook a souffle
you know that you're in capable hands i
can't wait for you to experience one
dream so prepare
to have your mind blown sign up now
through my special url to get this great
offer
a 14-day free trial with unlimited
access
just go to onedrive.com mindscape
that's w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash mindscape onerium.com
mindscape so how i mean how big is it
like what if i'm
if i uh get arrested at the state level
for selling drugs what is the chances
i'm going to end up in a private prison
depends on the state depends on who
they're contracting with depends on how
full their beds are i mean there's
there there are um many states that
because they've incarcerated so many
folks in their public institutions now
have had to reach out to private
institutions and are paying
to house individuals in their facilities
is it more costly to the state to have a
private prison
or you know so it this is so this is
really is
these questions are good they're they're
very difficult to answer because each
state is quite different
right okay so just to give you a
concrete example it's about 65
000 a year per individual to house in a
in a public facility in california okay
that's a number that more people more
politicians should be mentioning when
they're when they're talking about how
many people should be in prison
especially when you look at budgets
around education in california
yeah versus right right and i mean one
of the
one of the big stories of california is
how many prisons were built
you know in the last several decades
relative to new campuses say for example
in the uc system how much money is
funneled to
prison development versus education
and then even with that they're still
using private facilities in california
now
that's come down a bit um over the years
but that was a very scary trajectory
that was happening and from
our immigrant detention privatization is
still the primary way that that happens
right and he did put the finger on uh
the trump administration for the
immigrant issue in particular but
it's important to emphasize that
otherwise it's been a bipartisan push
right 100 yeah i mean i one of the
things that we talked when
when president obama was um
what you know when he was uh in a
president when he was president
they were referring to him as the
deporter-in-chief
they were you know it was a a detention
nation
um there's a lot that both sides have
done
to to kind of create restrictive harsh
exclusionary policy aimed at immigrants
right and i did want to you you wrote
another couple of papers that i thought
were just
worth getting on the table here even
though they're not in the direct line of
what we're talking about but you
mentioned the drug offenses and
how that's a lot of the prison
population and then we can discuss well
what should people be thrown in prison
for
and so you did some studies on the
relationship between legalizing
marijuana and suicide
and so letting pot be legal decreases
the suicide rate in some
sense is that right yeah i mean what the
what we
we used a really fancy methodological
approach to determine sort of what would
have happened to
suicide in california had had you know
basically had things continued as such
what did did legalizing marijuana
have an impact and yeah basically what
we found
was that it lowered suicide rates
and you know the main question is why
what are the mechanisms behind that what
accounts for that and that is
unexplored using the methodology that
that we did but we raised a series of
possibilities looking at
whether people are substituting
marijuana um
instead of alcohol alcohol causing you
know a lot of
mental health and other kinds of
problems so yeah there's
there's a there's uh generally i like to
look at the impacts of various policies
on a number of outcomes
i i keep my personal opinions about the
policies
out um in terms of legalization or these
reforms
but just there's so many claims around
the impacts of these policies and the
harms that they're going to cause and
create
yet very little research done on their
impact so my focus has always been well
what
what what is the impact of legalization
on
such and such outcome and what i really
liked about this study is actually
there's an interesting philosophy
question here
because it's easy to sort of just track
the you know number of suicides or
number of incarcerations or whatever and
like draw a line at where something is
legalized
but you went beyond that you constructed
an alternative world
in which it had not been legalized right
like you tried to model what it would
have been like because there's other
things going on
in the world right so there's some
counterfactual exploration
here which is actually philosophically
very interesting yeah my number one pet
peeve
with sort of the news reporting on these
sorts of policies
is what what they will typically do is a
policy gets enacted whatever that policy
is
people will follow what goes on with
crime it'll go up it'll go down
it'll stay the same and then they
immediately attribute any change in
crime to the policy
forgetting that that crime or any
outcome suicide for that matter is
a f is you know affected by
so many different factors um
i mean if you take crime for example we
can look at the role of guns
drugs gangs economic conditions
you know joblessness poverty demographic
shifts in the population other policies
policing right so crime is going to do
what it's going to do because a myriad
of factors if you want to isolate out
the impact of one particular policy
you have to do something a little more
sophisticated than look at
what crime trends do following that
policy and that's why we do the
synthetic control design method
do you since i don't know how different
fields uh tie together i mean there's
been a burgeoning
discourse in the idea of causality in
the social sciences judea pearl and
things like that are you
do you does that stuff impact what you
do yes love it okay
and my my former grad student who's now
a professor at the university of arizona
brad bartos he did his entire
dissertation on causality
and looking at the way in which um this
this approach the synthetic control
design method
addresses some of the biggest challenges
to determining causality
when you have a situation where you
can't conduct a pure experiment
right my field is very difficult i'd
love to experimentally assign
a policy to some states and not others
right that's never going to happen
and so we do these quasi experiments
um sort of the next best thing which has
all the benefits of an experimental
approach
it minus the random assignment if you
will um
to treatment or control and yeah so that
that is front and center there's
philosophical components of it that i
love and get into
and then there's also just like this
makes for a good way to test policy
right all right well thank you for
indulging my my philosophy i could talk
about that all day
but there's another philosophical
question i have actually so uh
moving into the sort of more
nitty-gritty of how people get um
incarcerated convicted etc but let me
still
lay some groundwork here i mean do you
this is
too much to ask but do you have a
feeling for what the right answer
is or should be to the question of why
should you incarcerate people
at all right there's punishment
deterrence rehabilitation there's all
the different
motivations and we're not very clear
necessarily about why we do it
what is the right answer i do not know
and i don't think it's one answer
i think it's historically contingent
it's contextualized
there's a lot of variation whether we're
talking at the local level the state
federal it's a it's complex and
um you know we're really good
criminologists are really good at
telling a wedding
telling everyone what they're doing
wrong it's a lot more difficult to come
up with solutions to those problems i
can tell you right now we're still
incarcerating too many people
and i can t you know i can identify
places where we're too harsh
or the policies are not working um so
like i fully supported all of the
reforms that california has enacted and
the research shows they're not causing
crime to go up
you know we need to start look that was
some of the lower hanging fruit right
it's easy for me to say well petty theft
you should not go to state prison at the
cost of 65
000 a year and serve out a long sentence
for petty theft
there are other ways to address that um
the question really comes well what
about violent individuals who have
engaged in violent crime
and i'm very sympathetic to victims and
others
i myself have been a victim of various
crimes including violent crime
and so i'm not one to just say abolish
the prisons
you know that we don't need we don't
need to incarcerate anybody because i do
think there are
individuals out there that can that are
dangerous and that need to be behind
bars because they're
producing lots of harm to society so
you know i'm not that extreme on that
end um
i certainly think there's still room for
reform so that's kind of where i situate
myself identifying very carefully
where it is that we can make changes um
recognizing that
um there's still room for improvement
but also not ready to kind of
throw the system out yeah no that's very
good and i i love the fact that you're
willing to say when you don't know what
the answer is to a question so
yeah not all podcast guests are quite so
honest with themselves so thank you for
that but
so i guess i guess one of the answers is
that you know different people involved
in the criminal justice system
might have different individual feelings
philosophies about why we're doing this
but you know often they line up and and
at least we would like to prevent crime
right and so we can say well
if a certain incarceration policy
doesn't prevent crimes
then why are we doing it that's part of
it for sure i mean
its impact on crime is is key but
there's other considerations
like you know maintaining um the values
that underlie our
system of democracy just you know just
a just system a fair system that even if
even if a policy
might lower crime if it's not fair or
just um you know we we can question
whether that's a useful policy
uh you know questions around retribution
or rehabilitation
like what are the values that underlie
our system and i think they're so varied
and
and you know if if a policy
doesn't limit crime but um
uh doesn't increase it either and is
more humane what do we feel about that
policy
sure yeah so it's a it's a heavy topic
yeah it is but you know you're in it
you're the one who has to think about it
i i don't i think about the universe
it's very non-valued
it's just the laws of physics but you
know i did uh
when i was in high school i was on the
debate team and we had
uh you know the debate topic that year
was a criminal justice topic so that
that was my last exposure
i won't say how many years ago but i
remember topic
oh it was about the exclusionary rule in
the fourth amendment right
um no actually sorry it wasn't
our case was about the exclusionary rule
and the fourth amendment the the
the topic was just about uh criminal
justice reform more broadly and i forget
exactly it's like
the united states should enact
large-scale criminal justice reform
um but i remember the motto that it
would be better uh
that a thousand guilty people go free
than that one innocent person be
convicted
we're clearly nowhere near that right i
mean just in uh
capital cases once dna came in we
realized holy crap we've been
finding a lot of people guilty uh who
we're not i mean what is your feeling
about the reliability of the criminal
justice system in actually
incarcerating people who were guilty at
least nominally of the crimes they're
being
accused of right this is the tension in
our system and it goes back i mean
criminologists have and and theorists
have been writing about this for
decades on the one hand we can we can
value crime control
and the processing of cases through the
system as quickly and expediently as
possible
you know um dealing with the large
caseloads that we have
i mean this is part of our problem is
that you know
the vast majority of people never go to
trial they plead guilty why because our
system is overloaded
so they're not even exercising those
rights that we so
fundamentally hold and value right on
the other end of the
if you think of that as one model
efficiency crime control
um handling the large case load on the
other end is sort of the due process
model
which says um you know and i the first
one i like into more like a
a an assembly line it's assembly line
justice right
we're getting most people through um on
the other hand
errors are happening but we're willing
to tolerate those errors in the larger
goal of
of of processing and efficiency
then there's the other end the due
process end which i liken more to a
an obstacle course the goal really is to
root out people of the system early on
so that we're not producing error
right the problem is is that in that
ideal role everyone's going to trial
every stage of the system is slowing
down to make sure errors are not
happening it's not functional in our
society
and there's a resource limitation right
it's a exactly
and so you know those are the ideals in
in some way the sort of theoretical
ideals and our system is somewhere in
the middle and we can debate all of that
so
how many errors are we willing to
withstand to make sure for example
that people are processed through the
system and justice is done
right if you're a victim and the
individual that
that the offender that victimized you
is their case is thrown out because they
weren't
arrested or they weren't um charged
within 48 hours of being arrested
which is is the rule and that case is
thrown out right is justice being done
so there has to be some processing that
happens
um the question is how much error are we
tolerating now
when it comes to the death penalty the
answer should be zero
right and this is the big this debate
we've seen the most play out with
respect to the death penalty because of
errors and
the the consequences of those errors
it's interesting because it
actually reminds me of richard feynman
being on the
challenger disaster committee he went
and uh
interviewed a bunch of uh engineers at
nasa and higher-ups at nasa
and when he talked to the higher-ups at
nasa he said you know what in your mind
was the acceptable
failure rate for the launches of a space
shuttle and they said zero percent
uh and he said but that is literally
physically impossible you could never
have zero
they were clearly just saying that
because they couldn't possibly quote a
number politically
exactly and and presumably the same
thing is true in criminal justice the
only way to get zero percent
failure rate even in capital cases is
just not to have the death penalty right
right absolutely i mean that and yeah so
and these are these are
it's funny because when you ask the
question what is that percentage
nobody's going to say a percentage like
that and that's why these are nice
theoretical models that we can debate
about
but at the end of the day um yeah these
are these numbers
are not something that anyone has an
appetite to discuss
yeah so no one is going to say well
we'll accept
0.1 percent of our verdicts being false
but what they will say is
we can't afford to spend all this money
doing every
trial at in all of its glory right
yep and so we have a problem then with
things like
again i'm not an expert here help me
with things like the public defender
system you know a lot of these
uh uh uh i
would say clients uh suspects what are
they called
accused clients is actually the right
term yeah okay
um you know they they are given a public
defender who's overworked makes makes a
lot of mistakes i mean how much is that
one of the problems
in getting that uh failure rate down as
low as we can
i think yeah it's hard to pinpoint what
you know what
accounts for these errors because
there's so many different factors
involved but certainly
um an overburdened system and that is
part of
the overburdened system now i mean the
the thing about public defenders is even
though they have large caseloads they
also have
very good working relationships with
other members of the court including
the judge and the prosecutor so they're
often able to make
very good plea deals okay um and they're
part of the courtroom work group so
there's you know there's advantages and
disadvantages but
certainly you know one of the other old
sayings is if you look to see who's on
death row you're never going to find
someone with a lot of money on death row
right so yeah
having money being able to afford a
whole
pile of attorneys that are going to
push to to to advocate on your behalf
is a huge huge plus i mean this
and and there's other ways like with
respect to bail right
right now there's a lot of debate about
whether cash bail should be part of the
system or not
right it disadvantages those that don't
have access to cash
um and we know that a lot there's a
large correlation between being put
behind bars
you know pre-trial detention and your
outcome
so money is and and and resources are
definitely a key part of this is there a
simple
explanation beyond just well good
lawyers are good
as to why we have this impression that
you can
if you're sufficiently wealthy buy your
way out of almost any conviction
oh it goes to so many different things
so you can do studies early on
to identify who the ideal juror is for a
case
right so if you have resources you can
do interviews
focus groups the attorneys can
identify who ideal jurors are they are
able to
um you know at every stage of the way
they're able to
use those resources to help the client
in their case get certain kinds of
experts present in the courtroom high
pay you know high cost expert witnesses
that will come in and and help the case
right just at different stages like that
but it's interesting so it's not just
straight out corruption it's just that
there's so many moving parts that if you
have enormous resources you can game all
of them to maximize your chances of
getting
exactly okay
hiring people is something that is
fraught with peril as well as promise
it sure helps when you can narrow down
the list to only really great choices
first
so you're not choosing between good and
bad but good and great
that's what you get with indeed indeed
is the job site that makes hiring as
easy as one two three
post screen and interview all on indeed
you can get a quality short list of
candidates whose resumes on indeed match
your description
faster you only pay for the candidates
that meet your must-have qualifications
and you can schedule and complete video
interviews in your indeed dashboard
with tools like indeed instant match
which gives you quality candidates
whose resumes on indeed fit your job
description immediately
and indeed skills tests that on average
reduce hiring time by 27 percent
so get started right now with a free 75
sponsored job credit
to upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 job credit
on indeed.com mindscape offer valid
through june 30th
terms and conditions apply and on the
other side of things i mean i can't let
us
go by without talking about uh people
who probably do not have a lot of
high-powered
lawyers which are rappers you know he
got a lot of specificity
that's true the ones who've made it
already they can probably afford the
best lawyers and others might disagree
with that
right jay-z can afford whatever lawyers
he needs but uh yes so you've done this
fascinating work where
um prosecutors would you know
for on whatever evidence they might have
bring up to trial a defendant
uh who they find has written their own
rap lyrics so we're not
we're not talking about rap lyrics that
are sort of in the air and on the radio
but these are
lyrics written by the defendant and well
you tell us
what happens here yeah basically rappers
aspiring rappers
are having their lyrics used against
them in in criminal cases
and prosecutors are making the claim
either that the lyrics are so
threatening that the individual is
communicating a terrorist threat
so the lyrics themselves are the crime
or they're arguing that the lyrics
represent sort of i
you know identity or motive with respect
to some other alleged crime
because the assumption is that that rap
music is nothing more than
autobiographical confessions
you know it's not art it's it's rappers
confessing to crimes in the lines
yeah bragging exactly and so they will
so what what how do they actually bring
that into the court
so they basically um you know along in
their case they will treat that as
evidence
and often it's the only evidence they
have about the individual that's being
charged with xyz
crime and so the lyrics come in the
videos come in
uh as evidence the judge allows that
evidence in
and the next thing you know this
extremely stereotypical
biased evidence for reasons i can get
into
is part of a trial where the jurors are
told
that these are confessions to crimes
right
so why is it biased go into that well so
you know what i just to back up and give
some context to this
i i when i was a brand new assistant
professor i've always listened to hip
hop
i had this idea of treating rap lyrics
as data
sort of thinking about um different ways
that we could
um well yeah basically
thinking outside of the box in terms of
data and i thought well rappers have a
lot to say
and they have a lot to say of interest
around crime and violence and
problematic policing and all sorts of
things
and i did content analyses of rap music
lyrics in very systematic ways which i'm
happy to talk about
analyzing over 400 songs in a 10-year
period
and published a series of papers where i
used the rap lyrics as data exploring a
variety of themes around violence and
crime and so on and so forth
then in 2011 got contacted by an
attorney who came across these content
analysis papers of mine
because he had a client an aspiring
rapper whose lyrics were
being used against him in you know
arguing that they were
communicating a terrorist threat and
they and this attorney wanted me to do a
content analysis
of these lyrics to talk about whether
these in fact were
actual threats or just the stuff of rap
so i did i testified in that case
fast forward several years i've
testified in many cases i've consulted
on dozens of cases
a conclusion from those experiences was
wow these lyrics you know are
literally
i could see it on the faces of the
jurors
i liken it to if you've never seen a
horror movie
and then you get dragged to see texas
chainsaw massacre
and you know you're just taken aback so
most of the jurors in these cases don't
know anything about rap music they
certainly don't know much about gangster
rap which is the subgenre here
there's lots of violence there's lots of
threatening language now
as a listener of rap this is pretty much
par for the course
so i noticed immediately that the effect
of these lyrics
was was sort of biasing in other words
the jurors were unable to evaluate the
content of the lyrics
apart from stereotypes and assumptions
that they had about
not only the rap lyrics themselves but
rappers who make them so i conducted a
ser sorry i know this is long but
no please i conducted a series of
experiments to try and determine if this
my hunch was in fact uh the case
and the experiments that i ran and these
were true experiments where we were able
to randomly assign
people um to conditions of being exposed
to rap lyrics versus violent lyrics that
were other music genres right if that
impacted people's evaluation and we
found out that it did
interesting and and just to be super
duper clear what we're saying here is
that someone can get arrested
a crime has been committed right more or
less all we know about this person is
you know maybe they owned a gun
or maybe they had the opportunity and
they wrote these lyrics
and no other evidence and they get
convicted on the basis of that
right and so my attitude is i don't know
whether the person's guilty or not i
i have no idea but using rap lyrics as a
shortcut
to bypass a proper you know trial if you
will
is problematic if there is physical
evidence
you know the gun you know if there's
eyewitness testimony if there's other
kinds of
evidence that should be the evidence
that leads to the conviction not
someone's
lyrics that they penned on a paper five
years ago
that maybe talk about killings and
shootings but
have nothing to do with the case at hand
so often what you get are the facts of a
case
and then the prosecutor trying to line
up the lyrics with the facts of the case
the lyrics are quite generic they're
very common you can find them in most
rap songs
they have no bearing on the actual fact
of the case and
if i recall from what the papers you've
written it is something special about
the fact that these are hip-hop lyrics
rather than country music or heavy metal
that's exactly the point so what we did
in our experiment was we um
we found some violent lyrics they're
actually lyrics from a folk song
batman's blunder by kingston trio
and just a couple of stanzas from them
and what we did was we randomly assigned
people to be told that these were rap
lyrics
or country music lyrics or heavy metal
lyrics in another set of experiments
that we did
and then we asked people to read the
lyrics and we asked them to evaluate the
lyrics on a number of dimensions how
threatening are they how dangerous
are they should they be censored not
played on the radio
do you think the the artist actually did
what they're saying in the lyrics
and depending on which uh set of lyrics
you were assigned
the rap heavy metal right um
the evaluations changed significantly
right so those that were
told they were rap lyrics evaluated them
much much more negatively and most
importantly saw them as
more literal and autobiographical
compared to those respondents in our
study who thought that they were heavy
metal or
country music lyrics the kingston trio
those notorious gangster rappers
there you go and if i if i remember
correctly
it was actually not correlated with what
the uh
people being studied thought the race of
the artist was it was
the music genre was more important than
race yeah and i don't know so the thing
so let me just back up and say so when
once we we did this study and we found
that there was this
impact and by the way we also found that
it wasn't just the lyrics that were
negatively evaluated
it was the artist himself so when we
we assigned artist status to each set of
lyrics
this is a rapper right then we ask
people to evaluate the character of the
artist
you think this artist is smart
intelligent
um a nice person engaged in criminal
activity a gang member
those who thought the lyrics were
written by a rapper right
much more negative character then we
wanted to understand what's going on
here is this rap
is this race is it some combination of
the two and you know we tried to isolate
out race by
by having conditions where the wrapper
was white versus the rapper was
non-white right this sort of thing black
and it turned out that it was a very
muddy kind of
set of findings we didn't find that you
could isolate out race in a way that was
significant
per your comment however when we didn't
this is very difficult to explain but
but let me just put it this way when we
didn't
identify the race but asked the
individual in the rap condition to
suggest the race
right they most frequently suggested
that this person was a person of color
african-american
so we think race is a definitely a part
of this
equation it's just very difficult to
separate out
all of these things yeah no i mean i
think that would be the lesson that i
would draw it's not that there's no
racism there racism doesn't matter but
that
there's a whole bunch of factors that
are in a stew that are mixed up
and uh that's why your job is much
harder than mine as a physicist that's
why i cannot
imagine studying human beings it's the
perfect definition of intersectionality
because it's not just
you know that these folks are black
they are young men mainly
from inner city communities that are
aspiring rappers
so it's all of it together so they're
practically guilty before that before
they even step in
when you yeah tell us about the content
analyses you mentioned
so um i was i when i was a graduate
student
we were reading works by famous
sociologists william julius wilson and
others
on sort of the large-scale macro changes
happening in society
and its impact on communities both
basically african-american communities
in terms of
crime and violence and everything from
de-industrialization
to the war on crime the war on all of it
war on drugs
and i was listening to hip-hop at the
time this was in the 90s the mid-90s and
i remember thinking
wow these rappers are rapping about
exactly what i'm reading about in
william julius wilson's the truly
disadvantaged of course they're not
calling it de-industrialization
but they're describing these changes and
that's when i got this idea of of using
rappers lyrics as data to kind of
illuminate some of these
theoretical concepts that i was seeing
my dissertation advisor told me don't do
that you'll never get a job
that cannot be your dissertation it's
too fringe nobody knows about hip-hop
this was the mid-90s
and so i i put it on the back burner
well when i got to be an assistant
professor
at george washington university i said
enough i'm doing this
and so i decided to do a content
analysis
identifying the various themes in these
key sociological
works um but doing it in a much more
systematic way than than i thought had
been happening in the field there was a
lot of sort of ideological work around
hip-hop
so i basically got every single album
rap album
that went platinum over an eight year
period
all of the songs off of those albums
okay
and then i got all of the lyrics from
all of those songs
thousands of them then i randomly
selected
a third of them which was about 600
songs
and then i started content analyzing
them one by one because they were
randomly selected i felt that i had the
universe there
um and after about song 430
i was i reached what is called
saturation in terms of the themes
line by line by line content analyzing
then i had an independent coder a
graduate student code a subset of those
so we could check for inner code of
reliability on all these different
themes
and then i started writing papers this
was a like a five-year project
it that produced many many papers but it
was very very long and arduous
and what do you what are you looking for
in the lyrics is it a commentary on
criminal justice or or talking about
doing crimes
right so i was looking at a variety of
themes i started
i had both a deductive and inductive
approach the deductive approach took a
couple of
theoretical frameworks like i mentioned
in william julius wilson's work
elijah anderson's code of the streets
and others
looking for themes around violence
misogyny
problematic policing but however as i
was content analyzing the lyrics
themes kind of bubbled up that i hadn't
anticipated
using these theoretical frameworks and
so i also incorporated those and one
just to give you a concrete example and
i don't know how familiar
you are with hip-hop of the 90s rap
music in the 90s but
a lot a lot i'm looking i'm waiting for
you
a little bit i'm not going to claim like
i'm older than that
i'm more you know uh um eric b rakim
kind of error
yeah yeah yeah uh i my kev likes to
think that he knows
rap of the 90s but you know i i it's
quite limited but so
i you know i i'm listening to these
songs in my sample
you know i would i would a song would
come up in my random selection
i'd listen to it a bunch of times get a
feel for it and i would listen to it
with the lyrics on the screen
coding line by line do that a couple of
times to make sure
one thing i noticed was wow rappers of
the 90s
obsessed about death and dying and the
afterlife
interesting and you know rappers like
snoop and dmx
and and um you know dre
and all all others they work tupac
biggie they were all talking about
i might die death is just a i mean
one of the papers that i wrote on
nihilism is called i see death around
the corner which is a tupac title
they were just obsessed with death and
dying and i got interested in that and
that wasn't really a part of any of the
paradigms that i
i the theoretical works i was dealing
with
and so i kind of that bubbled up from
the data and i ended up coding around
that and
wrote an entire paper on sort of
nihilism in rap music
and it's the point that you know there
was there was something that was being
perceived by these artists that was not
being perceived by the academics
exactly and one of it was you know a lot
of people say well
rappers and and folks in these
communities they they act irrationally
and you know what what how do we
understand violence like what is the
purpose why are you carrying around guns
what what is why is there so much
violence like
and a lot of what i was hearing um from
the rappers was this notion that like
tomorrow is not promised
yeah and death could be right around the
corner
and at any moment um your life can be
taken away from you and that was
the case for tupac and biggie two of the
people that spoke about right they were
right to have these fears
and you know the source of those fears
goes from everything from their
histories to the conditions in their
neighborhood
to the role of guns in the community to
these macro structural changes
to problematic policing and you know
in that context acting crazy
and and not caring about the future not
planning for the future kind of wilding
out
made sense and so i talk
you know it's quite rational behavior if
tomorrow isn't promised it doesn't make
sense to
buckle down and look to the future for
for your gratification so it was like
those kinds of themes that were
fascinating to me
and it's also this is just a complete
cliche but worth getting on the table
that um hop has always
been criticized by older school popular
musicians
by the fact that they're not playing
their instruments it's there's no
melodies things like that
but on the verbal side of things it's
just so
extremely more sophisticated and
accomplished than that
any typical pop lyricism that we've had
ever
right and that is exactly why i loved
hip-hop and continue to love hip-hop and
that's why it's flourished and has been
as successful as it has been
yeah and this is my problem with what i
call rap on trial the what with the
phenomenon we were talking about before
which is that rap is denied the status
of art
it's denied the status of poetry it's
it's and it is relegated to um
basically autobiographical confessions
and that is
extremely problematic to me and
it was racist quite frankly pretty darn
racist
i want to talk i think that there's very
interesting things
to be said about how art
can be thought of as evidence in the
criminal trials let me just ask the
most uh procedural question what are the
evidentiary rules
for a judge to just let someone's high
school poetry
into a trial right so obviously the
evidence has to be
proposed by the prosecutor
in these cases defense attorneys are
arguing vociferously to exclude
it um but they need help in terms of
making that case now in theory you are
not allowed to use what is called
character evidence in these cases
in other words evidence that speaks to
someone's character
and that's how prosecutors are
attempting to use this
and so what happens is that that that
prosecutors
what they want the jurors to hear is if
someone could write these lyrics
they could do the crime right that's
what i think is they're hoping is
happening
that's not allowed so basically but
they're finding ways around that by
arguing that the lyrics speak to the
motive identity or intent
of the individual with respect to the
alleged crime
i see so part of the maneuver is to deny
that this could be art
right to say that it must be a
straightforward autobiographical
confession
which if you sang it with country music
behind it you would not think
well and that's exactly the point name
me one other form of artistic expression
where this is happening in the courts
you can't
there is no other form of artistic
expression in other words defendant
authored lyrics that are being
introduced
into the court except when it comes to
rap music now
heavy metal cases have been in the
courts that's for a separate issue the
issue of incitement
but we're talking about defendant
authored lyrics
making an appearance in court that is
only for rap music
and you've said i think you've already
said this but i'll just want to hear it
again
uh it works that's bringing in these
violent lyrics uh
really does sway the juries absolutely
convictions are happening now
some cases are getting overturned at the
appellate level but most are not
and i think you know the goal
is to not get the lyrics in to begin
with
and defense attorneys come to me all the
time asking you know i'm filing a
pre-trial motion to exclude this
evidence
on these grounds i know it's i know it's
biased and stereotypical how do i show
that and i'm like well here's some
experimental research i've done
that actually documents that and i'm
currently working with a law professor
at uc irvine
um jack lerner and his students at a
clinic that he runs
we are producing a manual for defense
attorneys
that will help them navigate these cases
because many of them don't know much
about
rap music to begin with so they get the
videos they have
you know some of the same stereotypes
and assumptions even as they want to
help their client
and then you know given my experience
testifying in these cases you know i'm
able to provide some
context and and useful information about
how these cases basically go down if you
will so what if we're
i'm just trying my best here now to uh
to do the devil's advocate thing so
sure if i'm on the jury for one of these
trials and maybe it's specifically about
rapper whatever but
my big picture question is how much
context should i let inform my priors
about you know who this person is who
the defendant is where they come from i
mean there's
i in an ideal world you want to say well
there's the evidence of this case
but as a good bayesian i want to take my
my prior and multiply it by the evidence
the likelihood of the evidence right so
is there a theory of that or or do the
jurors get instructions about how to be
good babies
right so this is a really important part
of these cases so if the lyrics do get
allowed in the pre-trial motion
fails as it often does okay what is
absolutely
essential given my research i think
is that the jurors be educated on the
broader context of hip-hop and rap
these are the genre conventions right
right if you're an aspiring gangster
rapper
these are the kinds of themes that are
going to permeate your music
why do these themes permeate the music
because that's what makes
commercial success that's what gives you
respect as a rapper
so having that context having that
background
and understanding allows jurors to
properly
evaluate the evidence in the context of
the other evidence and the trial
not having that background information
is extremely problematic
in my case and that's where experts come
in to provide that context
right that makes sense yeah and and to
have an alternative explanation other
than
this is simply confession a violent
person you know
they're going to do it and uh i mean
since
i'm not very much out of the uh loop on
these things
how prevalent is gangster rap as a
sub-genre of hip-hop now as compared to
what it used to be like i had the
feeling that in the
early 90s or whatever it was it was it
was very high up there and maybe it's
less
prevalent now yeah and i'm not even sure
if you would even call it gangstar
there's so many sub-genres of rap music
right and i guess what we could talk
about is you know what percentage of
aspiring rappers
you know have themes of violence and
threat and misogyny in their lyrics and
i still think
it's pretty high now it may not be the
stuff you hear on the radio
or you know you're familiar with among
common rappers
but it is definitely definitely out
there at the amateur level
at the aspiring level good morning
it's it's huge and it's not just among
blacks it's among white rappers
and asian rappers and latino rappers it
is it is
definitely still the currency by which
you both
make money as a rapper and gain respect
as a rapper
so i think if you were yeah i mean
people are not rapping about
the the good you know the ha there's
just not like a lot
of will smith kind of rappers out there
but also when you're aspiring anything
you're in your teenage angsty period
right and you know the world is terrible
and you're going to explain it to people
exactly or or you're also going to
report what's going on in your community
right i mean a lot of cases involve
rappers that are frustrated with the
conditions in their communities with the
problematic police relations
and they are calling the police out in
it in threatening ways
right when does that become a problem
but when is it an actual threat
yeah no i mean that's a a legitimate
question i think
it's hard like like we've been saying
your job is very hard and
let me make it even harder by extending
from hip-hop lyrics to just
art more generally like what is the
general theory of
if i have someone who has created
something
lyrics poetry novels
videos right because everyone has an
iphone now they can make their own
videos
uh how much should that inform a juror's
deliberation about the
likelihood that they could have
committed the crime in front of them
right and this is the stuff that's
decided in the courts in these appellate
cases right figuring out if something
constitutes an actual threat or if it is
just i mean
you know that there's that question and
then there's also
you know why has quentin tarantino never
been
charged for the violence in his movies
you know why did
like the common example that we use all
the time is
uh johnny cash i shot a man in reno just
to watch him die like nobody would or
the dixie chicks kill earl um that the
former dixie chicks
um you know nobody would assume that
what's going on in that song
they're actually doing and so
what is it about rap um now there are
some nuances there that should be
addressed like rap claims authenticity
so you know right there's a component of
rap like i'm not just rapping about it
i'm doing it
yeah and yeah but and so that brings a
wrinkle in
but the point is is there's complexity
there it doesn't necessarily mean that
the rappers are doing that because if i
if every rapper did what they said they
were doing in their raps it'd be world
war three
up in this country well look you know i
mean that's sort of the point
every politician claims that they were
born in a blue collar family and you
know
drank beer and every everything like the
fact that you
think that authenticity is very
important does not imply you're
authentic
exactly and also there's a difference
between you know who you are as a person
and the character you play i mean this
is why rappers have stage names it's
like hulk hogan
right you know there's terry bollea and
then there's hulk hogan and when he's in
hulk hogan mode
he's going to say all kinds of crazy
things you know i'm going to rip your
head off and i'm going to do this that
and the other and
it's part of the character are there
lessons here for
things that are not quite art or even
aspire to be but nevertheless
might be brought in as evidence of what
this person is like like you know
personal diaries social media posts
things like that i mean
what are the rules as an outsider once
again for bringing that stuff in
to impugn the character of the defendant
yeah there
the rules are very difficult and i mean
it's very i mean as just a criminologist
i am not up on sort of the legal the
legal doctrine
around what is acceptable what is a true
threat right i know artistic expression
has certain
protections and for good reason um right
if i want to
critique the police in a song i sh you
know
because we we worry about a chilling
effect that that might have on speech
particularly artistic speech
artistic expression um but you know what
the
what all the intricacies of whether in a
particular instance
um lyrics from a song or just someone's
thoughts
represent a threat is like uh i mean i'd
have to go back to all those
supreme court cases where they're ruling
on this and and
understand the complexities there
it's difficult there's a lot going on i
mean let's let's start circling back a
little bit
um despite all this crime is going down
right i mean
you know we we've talked a little bit
about uh incarceration how high it is
the some of the inequities in the system
um but yet crime like maybe since 1990
or something like that has been going
down what
is our understanding of why that has
been happening well
um so first of all there's
as a criminologist we talk about crime
trends kind of at different
levels there's the societal level and we
can look at the societal factors like
economic conditions and that sort of
thing
we can look more at variation across
cities so i would argue that
crime is not going down in some cities
but it is in others
and then even within cities where crime
is going down you have sort of the
unequal distribution of that benefit
like in some neighborhoods crime is
going up so
it's a very complex question crime is
going down i'd say
i'd say on the on the broad scale
um mainly because socioeconomic i mean
let's take the crime drop because that's
a very defined period
criminologist so the crime drop ha so
remember i mentioned the crime drop
early on in the interview which is that
crime rates went
we're sort of consistently going down
starting about the early 90s through the
mid-2000s
okay because you know when you say
crime's going down
i i want to get like fixated well what
years are you talking about and yeah
because it's actually gone up and
yeah so let's let's pick a defined
period that everyone would agree that
crime sort of went down universally
which is the crime drop and we have
looked at a number of factors
responsible for the crime drop
including the sort of drying up of the
crack cocaine markets of the 80s
the economic boom of the 90s my own work
has looked a lot at the role of
demographic shifts in our society
including
a rise in immigration to cities in the
united states
so contrary to a lot of popular belief
immigration to an area causes crime to
go down
rather than up um you wouldn't know that
after our last administration but that's
that's in fact the case so these
large-scale
macro forces are what we tend to look at
to understand
crime booms and busts and there's the
freakonomics explanation of rovers as
well no it doesn't work yet
i thought that was kind of discounted
but i was sorry yeah no that's
that's that is uh we've moved on from
that
that's pretty much been debunked so i i
certainly
makes perfect sense to me that the
economy doing better in the 90s
uh would help crime go down and in some
sense it makes perfect sense to me that
the dissolution of the crack cocaine
epidemic would help but is it
is it mostly because people who were
addicted to crack
committed crimes or people got arrested
because they were on crack
no so basically the the recession of the
crack markets
involved people um it really the role of
firearms is central here
okay so when crack was very popular in
the 80s
and out and about in and individuals
were getting involved in selling crap
people were arming themselves with guns
because you can't turn to the police
when you have a prop when you've gotten
your drugs robbed off of you right
so um basically people started arming
themselves
this also meant that folks in these
communities who had nothing to do with
the crack cocaine market
but who navigated in these communities
also felt the need to arm themselves
in protection and we saw an upsurge in
in young people carrying firearms
okay well recall your statement earlier
about young people development
and and firearms right and so we saw a
surge in
in violence in the 80s due to these
due to this which when the markets
closed up and dried up
a lot of that gun violence and and
ended up going down so there's no rule
that says that when
an effect happens there's only one cause
of it there can be multiple causes
about a hundred percent that is exactly
why it is so difficult to i mean with
looking at something like controlling
crime or predicting crime
it's very challenging and that's why
statistics are our friend because we can
talk about probabilities
um without being you know needing to be
like
certain right we we can say with
with within a certain range of
probability
right more of this equals less of that
but
um this is my students will go well what
about and i go well
that still fits with statistics yeah
that's part of one
case does is is still works within our
statistical framework
when you did mention immigration as
something in particular i think that's
worth uh
being clear about because it is a messy
situation and politically highly charged
but
there's data out there and the the short
version is that i think it's true to say
that immigration does not
increase crime uh but what's the longer
version
so there is if there's one area that i
have done research in
where the findings are consistent and
clear it is this area
and that is both that immigrants have
lower
offending rates uh than their native
born peers
and that cri immigration to an area
causes either has no impact on crime or
causes it to go down
that's it and this has been reported in
studies
from the early 1900s through my
meta-analysis
and beyond i did a meta-analysis with
graham aussie at william and mary
we basically got every single study
published between 1994 and 2014 of which
there were over 50 studies
and we we did a meta-analysis sort of a
formal evaluation
of that literature looking at sort of
what the average effect
of uh you know of of of the immigration
on crime um sort of the average effect
of
immigration on crime across this body of
research was and it was null it was
basically a null relationship
um when there was um a significant
relationship
it was more likely to be negative than
positive meaning immigration
going up crime going down and what we
also found was predicting the
variability in
in in that the coefficients if you will
we found that studies that were
more robust that had more control
variables that had
longitudinal designs that means dealt
with causality better
showed a more a stronger negative effect
than positive effect so i mean every the
needle points in the direction
every single time of course both
immigrants
and uh people who are already here are
heterogeneous groups right there's all
sorts of different
people coming in there but is it
nevertheless uh
possible to go one step beyond what you
just said and explain why i mean
if there's a slight decrease in crime is
it because
uh immigrants are just a little bit more
um
careful about not offending the powers
to be because they don't want to be
kicked out or is it just because they're
selected to be
hardworking and trying to form a better
life or what can we say
you hit two of the big ones so the first
is the selection
the selection issue right obviously
folks coming over to the united states
not a random
cross-section of the population highly
selected hard-working
willing to delay gratification right
none of the characteristics associated
with criminality there's also the sort
of the fear
of maybe deportation or
coming into contact with authorities so
a deterrence perspective
there there's other factors though that
i think are interesting
we found in some research that
immigrants on average tend to have
lower rates of single-parent households
divorce
and other kinds of family disruption and
family disruption as a
at the macro level is correlated with
crime um
so you know again that's not to say that
that
immigrants aren't you know there aren't
households where divorce is happening
and that sort of thing but on
average they have lower rates statistics
they're also
they also have lower rates of
unemployment um
compared to native-born blacks and
whites particularly i mean even if
that's low-wage
employment it still helps offset poverty
and poverty being
a correlate of some crime so you know
there's a number of competing
explanations
some at the individual level some at the
more macro level
um and right now i've got a grant from
the national institute of justice that's
beginning to
try to parse out why you know which
mechanisms may be responsible for
this i guess maybe one thing worth
saying although correct me if it's
emphasizing the wrong thing but a lot of
the crimes we've been talking about
these violent crimes or drug crimes
uh we're excluding or not paying
attention to white-collar crimes very
much
right and that would be a very different
discourse it's not the it's not what we
think of when we think of these kinds of
crimes
a 100 percent the whole field
unfortunately criminology is obsessed
with what we call street crimes rather
than sweet crimes s-u-i-t-e
and that's hugely hugely problematic
yeah that would be a whole other podcast
maybe but okay
people who are in the in the suites are
still committing some crimes that's
that's
probably true in fact i don't know is it
more likely if you have an income
of over three hundred thousand dollars a
year that you're committing a crime
every year than if
you have one of under fifty thousand
dollars a year well let's put it this
way that the damage done is much greater
yeah okay
yeah i bet the probability is higher
because you're at least you know like
not paying all your taxes or something
like that right
exactly right so i mean yeah the
question is i mean for a long time that
many of these behaviors weren't even
considered criminal they're considered
like creative accounting or something
like that
100 yes there is plenty of white-collar
crime going around
all right so i i'd like to end the
podcast on an optimistic note if
possible but
i will let you decide whether we should
be optimistic or not crime did go down a
little bit during the crime drop i mean
are you optimistic about how we're doing
do you think the criminal justice system
is becoming a little bit more
good or efficient or sensible or just in
dealing with these or and if not
what's the one thing we can do to make
things better oh
that's a good question so you know
what's interesting is
kovid um you know we didn't talk at all
about sort of coveting crime
on the pandemic i should say in crime
because one of the really
interesting silver linings if you can
say something like that
to the pandemic was when everything shut
down
crime plummeted um i really it was
unbelievable to see the drops in crime i
mean part of that is nobody's going
anywhere
right so you know stores are shut down
so crime absolutely plummeted the scary
thing about that though
was that we saw it move online
and shift online in a way that get is
like a harbinger of the future for me
which is sort of how are we going to
deal with the complexities
of combating crime in the virtual space
which has really really taken off yeah
and i so i think as you know we move
forward and think about you know crime
going down
is it really going down is it being
displaced elsewhere
right and now by the way it's in some
places it's back up violent crime in
some cities is quite problematic
obviously mass shootings are a huge huge
problem so i think when we talk about
kind of run-of-the-mill crime
things seem good but there's a lot of
things so it's that's optimistic
pessimistically because i worry about
the mass mass shootings that are just
every day police violence a lot of the
you know what's happening in uh you know
to young men of color
and young women of color whose lives are
being taken
by misconduct by the police and other
police use of force
there's the online crime that has
shifted as we get more advanced and
and people are using technology more in
their daily lives
so those are my and then the
privatization thing to circle back to
that
those are like four areas that i i think
we need to be keeping our eye out on
when you mention online crime you know
what should we have in mind as the kind
of crime that is that is prevalent
online that you're worried about
everything from i mean you know recall
when
when people were scurrying around to
find masks right the sort of
all of that where they have these fake
products these problematic products or
people were getting their checks and
then they were
getting false emails to log in to get
your your check from the government
to you know um
bigger picture kinds of um
tax evasion stuff um
well yeah so i'm i'm i'm blanking on who
it was
that was remember they sold the stocks
at the last minute
oh which one the the senators yeah i
mean kelly loffler was one of them
yeah i forget but remember they unloaded
all of that and that just that kind of
it's it's it ranges from like the
individual who's selling
illegal goods online or who's stealing
people's
checks or are you know doing hate crime
online all of that from the individual
to these bigger kinds of
fraud yeah fraud so this is your
optimistic message that we're entering
an era of widespread fraud on the
internet that's on the horizon and we
need to figure out i mean us
criminologists we're so busy with our
street crime
well maybe the optimistic message is
that when you you mentioned the mass
shootings and
uh police brutality and things like that
maybe we're more
cognizant of that now maybe there will
be a
momentum to try to clean that up a
little bit i don't know oh one
yes i i agree i think that's there's
recognition of these
issues as problems and there's an
awareness
um and so we just need to figure out how
we're going to stay one step ahead on
all of this
and and reform where reform needs to
happen
those are all very wise words i think
that's a very good ending place shares
kubrin thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast
thank you i enjoyed it
[Music]
you